اهلا بكم تسلمت الشرطه العسكريه اليمنيه
مبنى المجمع الحكومي لمحافظه عمران من
المسلحين الحوثيين وذلك بموجب تفاهم بين
الطرفين بعد سقوطها في ايديهم قبل نحو ع
ايام نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل يمكن ان يكون هذا التفاهم بين
الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين مؤشرا على
بدايه انفراج العلاقه بين
الطرفين وما هي الضمانات المطلوبه لتفادي
تكرار ما حدث في عمران مؤخرا في
المستقبل رغم تسلم الجيش اليمني مبنى
المجمع الحكومي في مدينه عمران من
المسلحين الحوثي الى ان الحكومه اليمنيه
ما زالت تعتبر ذلك خطوه غير مجتمعه وعبرت
صنعاء عن استيا مما سمته مماطله جماعه
الحوثي في الانسحاب من محافظه
عمران حاله من الترقب والخوف من المجهول
تسود الشارع السياسيه والامنيه في اليمن
العنوان محافظه عمران القريبه من العاصمه
صنعاء حيث يستمر سريان اتفاق رمته وزاره
الدفاع مع المسلحين الحوثيين الذين كانوا
يسيطرون على مدينه عمران ويتم بموجبه
تسليم مرافق المدينه المختلفه للجيش وياتي
هذا التطور في اعقاب اشتباكات عنيفه تجددت
في المحافظه ومحيطها منذ الثامن من يوليو
عقب انهيار اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار مبرم
مع الحكومه لم يصمد سوى ايم علامات
استفهام كثيره تحيط بامكانيه صمود الاتفاق
الراهن في ظل مرابطه بعض المسلحين في تخوم
المدينه وان كان الحوثيون يؤكدون انتفاء
مبررات وجودهم المسلح في عمران بعد
تطهيرها ممن يسمونهم بالتكفيريين وهي
الصفه التي يطلقونها على انصار حزب
الاصلاح وهناك من القوى السياسيه والقبليه
في عمران من يعتقد بان الحوثيين لم
ينسحبوا اصلا من عمران بل اعادوا انتشارهم
في المحافظه التفافا وتحلا على قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي وغيره من المواقف الاقليميه
المندده بنشاطهم في عمران
وتداعياته كثيرون يربطون بين الاحوال
الراهنه في المحافظه وضعف اداء الجيش وبطء
اعاده هيكليتها مما يغري المسلحين
الحوثيين وغيرهم لممارسه لعبه القط والفار
مع الحكومه في اطار معادله تقويه المواقف
وتوسيع رقعه النفوذ قبيل تحول اليمن
المرتقب لدوله الاتحاديه لكن الرئيس عبد
رب منصور هادي يعول كثيرا على الجيش جنبا
الى جنب مع المجتمع اليمني لوزن مختلف
الاختلالات ويحذر بان عرقله تنفيذ قرارات
مؤتمر الحوار الوطني واستمرار العنف ستكون
له نتائج وخيمه على تقدم العمليه
الانتقاليه في اليمن على كل حال اتفاق
عمران الراهن يبدو حاليا على الاقل قد
اطفى لهيب المواجهات الداميه في المحافظه
لكن كثيرين ومنهم بعض قبائل المنطقه
يتخوفون من المراحل القادمه خاصه وان
المواجهات مع الحوثيين مشتعله قريبا منهم
في محافظه
الجوف معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو
الكاتب والباحث اليمني
جمال المليكي ومعنا من صنعاء عارف ابو
حاتم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ونحن في
انتظار ان ينضم الينا ايضا من صنعاه محمد
العماد نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا لو بدانا
بالاستديو سيد جمال المليكي ما جرى
في عمران من تفاهم بين الحكومه
والحوثيين هل يمكن ان يبني علاقه جديده
بين الجانبين نعتقد ان هناك ما ما يطمن
المجتمع اليمني اليوم من كل ما حدث للاسف
الشديد الضحيه الرئيسيه من الصراع الموجود
اليوم هو ذلك الحلم الذي تشكل في ساحات
وميادين التغيير في اليمن ليس هناك ضحيه
اخرى ليس هناك غالب ومغلوب سوى هذا الحلم
الذي بدا بالتشكل وبدا بالاقتراب من خطوات
التحقق الاولى للاسف الشديد الكل يعني
ساهم بشكل او باخر باغتيال هذا الحلم
الاخوه الحوثيين لم يكونوا اوفياء للثوره
التي مكنتهم من هذا الانتشار والتي جعلت
وضعهم اكثر بكثير من ايام النظام السابق
وللاسف الشديد مارسوا مارسوا اغتيال هذا
الحلم ب بطريقه تفكك فلسفه الفكره يعني هم
يتبنوا منذ البدايه يعني منذ ايام الثوره
كان هناك محاوله للتوسع المسلح في الجوف
في ذات ايام الثوره بعد ذلك تبنوا هذه
الاستراتيجيه التي تتعارض فلسفيا وجوهريا
مع فكره الشباب التي جاؤوا بها الى
الساحات والتي كادت ان تفتك لنا المستقبل
الجميل الذي يحلم به اليمني البسيط اذا
القوى الاخرى للاسف الشديد على سبيل
المثال لقاء المشترك علي عبد الله صالح لم
يستطع ان يفكك اللقاء المشترك خلال الفتره
السابقه الصراع القائم للاسف الشديد هناك
من يرى انه استطاع اليوم لم نجد موقفا
واحده للقاء المشترك بما حصل بالعكس هناك
استثمار وموا حكات تستثمر الصراع الموجود
في عمران
لكي يغلب يعني فصيل فصيل اخر داخل اللقاء
المشترك نفسه اذا هناك ال يعني حاله من من
من الغم دعني اقول من التخلي عن المسؤوليه
الضميريه حتى الحكومه اليوم يعني الرئاسه
اليمنيه حتى اللحظه ليس هناك موقف واضح
الموقف الغامض يجعل يعني يجعل المقترب من
المشهد في اليمن يعني يفتح السؤال على كل
الافق يعني يسقط لواء يقتل قائد في الجيش
ثم لا نسمع حتى هذه اللحظه من يلمح حتى
تلميح لمصير هذا اللواء او المصير كيف حدث
يعني لم لم تتبنى الدوله مسؤوليتها في
مكاشفه المجتمع ما الذي حصل على الاقل
ولكن على الاقل الواضح هنا اسال سيد عارف
ابو حاتم على الاقل الواضح ان هناك
ترتيبات معينه او تفاهمات معينه جرت بين
وزاره الدفاع يعني بين الحكومه والحوثيين
ويقضي بتسليم المباني الرسميه من محافظه
ومقرات اخرى في عمران بعد ان سيطروا عليها
في الفتره الماضيه هل هذا يمكن ان يوحي
بان ربما التفاهم بين الجانبين يمكن ان
يمتد الى ما هو ابعد من
ذلك للاسف الشديد جميع اللجان الرئاسيه
والتعاملات
مع اللجان ومع الاتفاقيات التي تتم مع مع
الحكومه يتعامل معها الحوثيون باعتبارها
عربات اطفاء يلجؤون اليها عند عند حاجتهم
اليها عند اضطرارهم لها كاض طرار اخلاقي
او كاض طرار عسكري اذا ما وجهو هزائم في
الميدان لكن ما احب التاكيد عليه هو ان
سقوط عمران وما حدث في عمران قبل ذلك مع
اولاد الاحمر كل ذلك كان تداعيات لما حصل
في دماج في حرب دماج كاد الحوثيون ان
يختنق كادوا ان ينتهوا كانوا في حاله هي
الاشد الاقسى منذ الحرب منذ حرب صعده
الاولى التف الجميع ضدهم وضد
ال النازيه التي يمارسونها ضد الناس بعد
ذلك وبقدره قادر وكان احد المشايخ ومن
تدخل في المساله وفي البيعه وحصل التهجير
الطائفي الذي الاول من نوعه في اليمن بعد
هذا الذي سبب الذي اعطى الحوثيين نشوه
انتصار زامنه و واكبه تغطيه اعلاميه مهوله
جدا لما حصل لهم بعد ذلك
ا انتصارهم الاعلامي على ال الاحمر هذا
الذي اعطاهم هذا الزخم كله و على ذكر ال
الاحمر سييد عارف على ذكر ال الاحمر
الحوثيون يكررون باستمرار بانهم ليسوا في
صراع مع الدوله وبانهم لا ليس من خطتهم
ضرب الدوله اليمنيه وانما هم يحاربون كما
يقولون
ايه ناس تكفيريين في
تيار الاصلاح
وان هؤلاء يتحملون مسؤوليه حتى في الاحمر
تحديدا علي محسن الاحمر يتحمل مسؤوليه على
كل الحروب السابقه الي التي كان فيها هو
عدوا شرسا لما كان هو مع الرئيس علي عبد
الله صالح الان على كل بغض النظر عن
الخلفيه التاريخيه اذا بقينا في ما جرى في
عمران الان هناك تفاهم وهناك تجاوب معين
حتى وان كانت الحكومه تعتبر ان هناك بعض
المماطله هل ما يجري
مطمئن ما يجري ليس مطمئنا اما مصطلح
تكفيريين هذا المصطلح تلق تلقونه الحوثيون
الحوثيين هديه من السفاره الامريكيه بان
استخدام مصطلح تكفيريين سيخدم كثيرا عندما
كانوا في الحرب مع السلفيين وتم نقله الى
دماج الى الى عمران ما احب التاكيد عليه
ان الحوثيين اصغر واضعف من ان يسقطوا
اللواء 310 اقوى لواء عسكري في اليمن من
اسقط اللواء العسكري كانوا مجاميع من
القوات الخاصه كبيره جدا عادم يفوق 5 من
ممن يوادون الرئيس السابق ونجله عد الحرس
الجمهوري السابق وتم تسليمهم اسلحه نوعيه
اضافه الى بعض التواطؤ من الداخل والا كيف
حصلوا على 50 طقم برشاشات عسكريه تتبع
القوات الخاصه والنجده والامن العام
واقتحموا من الجهات البوابه الشماليه عند
مبنى القياده جه منطقه تسمى القشله الذي
دخلوا من هذ اللواء القشيبي وقتلوه وكيف
تم كيف تم كل ذلك الان ما هو مطلوب من
الدوله ومن الحكومه ان تتحمل مسؤوليه
القانونيه والتاريخيه والاخلاقيه وتقدم
للناس بيان توضيحي تقول لهم ما الذي حدث
الذي حدث الان هناك قتله باكثر من 200
جندي وضابط الذي حدث ان هناك نهب لعتاد
عسكريه تجاوز قيمته لمليار دولار 50 دبابه
45 مدرعه 25 مصفحه منصتي صواريخ 800 صارخ
كاتوشا
202 طقم رشاش يحملون مض ولكن سيد ابو حد
انت انت تتحدث الان اسمح لي انت تتحدث
الان اسمح لي انت تتحدث عن مخلفات المعركه
ولكن هناك بعد هذه المعركه كانت هناك
تفاهمات هنا اعود مره اخرى للسيد جمال
المليكي يعني حتى نبقى في موضوع يعني اسمح
لي فقط حتى نبقى في موضوع ما جرى في في في
عمران جرت مواجهات ضرب اللواء 310 مثل ما
قال قتل قائده الان هناك تفاهمات تجري في
في عمران تقضي بتسليم المباني الحكوميه
واعادتها للحكومه هل تعتبر ان فعلا هناك
مماطله في هذه الخطوات كما تتهم الحكومه
الحوثيين ودعني اقول ما الذي لا يجعلنا
نطمئن على الاقل عندما نقترب من المشهد ان
شيء من هذا سيحدث هو الغموض السائد يعني
لواء يسقط على سبيل المثال دعنا نوسع يعني
لحظه السقوط كيف حدثت بالاضافه الى ما ذكر
صديق عارف الفكره هي
ان رئيس الجمهوريه يغادر البلد الى
السعوديه وزير الدفاع في ذات اليوم يغادر
الى الامارات يسقط هذا اللواء يعود الرئيس
ويعود وزير الدفاع ثم لا يتم توضيح لم تتم
احترام عقل الانسان اليمني ولا كرامه
الانسان اليمني ان يوضح له ما الذي حدث
لجيشه الا اذا كان الا اذا كان الجيش او
وزاره الدفاع تتعامل مع هذا اللواء فعلا
انه ليس لواء تابعا لوزاره الدفاع تبدا
المسؤوليه لماذا لم يتم توضيح هذا للمجتمع
حتى يعرف من الذي عمليا يعيق التحول
الحقيقي اذا في ظل هذا الغموض وفي ظل يعني
ما يعتبره البعض يعني هناك تحالف لا شك ان
النظام السابق نظام يعني انتزع منه الحكم
انتزاع سيستثمر هذا الوضع هناك علاقه يعني
من متابعه الاعلام
كلام النظام السابق ومن متابعه
ايضا التصريحات لقادته هناك تنسيق واضح هو
الذي ساعد الحوثييين في هذا طيب ما موقف
الرئاسه من هذا التحالف كيف يمكن ان نوضح
للمجتمع حتى نستطيع ان نطمئن ان هناك
تفاهمات حقيقيه لكن كل ما يحدث اليوم هو
غير واضح لا للباحث المقترب بالتجرد ولا
للانسان اليمني العايش داخل اليمن ولا حتى
للذي لاطراف لبعض اطراف النزاع هناك حاله
من الاستثمار هناك هناك من يرى انه على
سبيل المثال هل يعني الرئيس يريد ان
يستثمر ان يتم انهاك جميع القوى السياسيه
حتى يستثمر وضع هناك من يرى ايضا هذا
التحليل الذي يجعل كل كل التحليلات مفتوحه
على الاحتمال هو الغموض الذي لم تجليه ولم
تتعامل الحكومه اليمنيه ولا الرئاسه
بشفافيه مع المجتمع ولا مع الراي العام
بالاضافه الى اذا وسعنا اكثر المزاج
السياسي الموجود في الاقليم من يعني
الحوثيين يصروا على ان يستخدموا ان صراعهم
مع الاصلاح هم يريدوا ان يستثمروا المزاج
السياسي الموجود في الاقليم في محاربه كل
ما له علاقه بالاخوان المسلمين ف وعلى فكر
الحوثييين اسمح لي فقط بالمقاطعه لان كان
يفترض يكون معنا السيد محمد العماد وهو
خبير في شؤون الحوثيين على الاقل
يعطي وجهه نظر لما يفكر فيه الحوثيون
لاننا حريصون على ان تكون كل وجهات النظر
موجوده ولكن للاسف لحد الان سييد محمد
العماد لم ينضم الينا وبالتالي هناك وجهه
نظر تتعلق بالحوثيين غير موجوده لحد الان
سنحاول ان نعوضها قدر الامكان حتى نفهم
السياق اليمني للاحداث اذا عدنا للسيد
عارف اذا على الاقل خ يعني اذا اردنا ان
نلخص منذ بدايه الحلقه لا السيد عارف ولا
السيد جمال يعتقدان بان ما جرى هو يمثل
انفراجه معينه هو يبدو يعني لا يمثل شيء
معنا الان معنا ايذا محمد العماد عبر عبر
الهاتف سيد محمد كنت سالت ضيفين قبل قليل
السيد جمال المليكي والسيد عارف ابو حاتم
من صنعاء عما اذا كان ما يجري الان في
عمران من ترتيب تسليم المباني من
الحوثييين الى السلطه الحكوميه يمثل بدايه
انفراج هل تراه
كذلك بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اشكرك بدايه ان شاء الله وما يتمناه
الجميع بان مساله تسلم مكان الونيه وما تم
وجود الكادر لجنات
ال المحافظه
و مجرات اخرى
هي لاحمال السلام بشكل عام على مستوى
اليمن يعني للاسف حتى نوعيه الصوت ليست
جيده عبر عبر الهاتف سنحاول تلافي ذلك
اعود الى السيد عارف ابو حاتم او خلينا
ناخذ فاصل احسن خلينا ناخذ فاصل فاصل
ونتطرق الى النقطه الثانيه في هذه الحلقه
وتتعلق بكيف يمكن عبر ضمانات معينه ان
نتلافى ما حصل
في عمران في الفتره الماضيه لنا عوده نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلنا معكم في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها التفاهمات التي
جرت مؤخرا بين الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين
لتسليم المباني الرسميه في مدينه عمران
سيد عارف ابو حاتم اذا اردنا ان
ايه نعرف ما هي الضمانات التي يمكن ان
توفرت في المستقبل يمكن الا يتكرر ما حدث
مؤخرا في عمران ما
هي اولا انت في السابق ان تسال عن مساله
التفاهمات هل هي بدايه انفراج ليست بدايه
انفراج لان كل الشواهد التاريخيه تقول ان
الحوثيين ما وافقوا او لم يلتزموا بنص او
بند واحد وقعوا عليه انا انا تحدث منطلقا
من شواهد تاريخيه مساله الضمانات ل حتى لا
تتكرر مثل ما حدث في عمران لا ضمان اكثر
من تسليم ترسانه الدوله وسلاح الدوله الى
الدوله ان تكون الدوله هي المالك الشرعي
والوحيد للسلاح هذا هو الضمان الاكبر
عندما التقى ممثل رئيس اللجنه الرئاسيه
عبد الملك المخلافي بعبد الملك الحوثي في
صعده ناقش معه مساله حزب انشاء حزب
السياسي والتحول الى حزب سياسي مدني قال
له عبد الملك الحوثي لدينا تجربه مريره مع
الاحزاب وسابقا شكلنا حزب سياسي و حسب
الحق وكان علي عبد الله صالح يوم يشطب
ويوم يشقه نصفين ويوم يفرخ لذك مررا مع
الاحزاب حاول اقنعه بان النظام تغير
والرئيس تغير لم يقتنع التجربه المساله
الثانيه بحثها مع تسليم السلاح قدم مبررات
وهي قال له علي معنا ثار مع اولاد الاحمر
مع علي محسين الاحمر مع السلفيين نحن
بحاجه الى ان نبقى بسلاحنا مع انه لا
يتكلم عن كلاشنكوف او مسدس هو يتكلم عن
دبابه وصاروخ مدفع النقطه الثالثه كان مص
الانتقال الى صنعاء وقال سافتح مكتب سياسي
في صنعاء هنا المخلافي قال له اذا كنت
ستفتح مكتب في صنعاء فيجب ان يكون له كامل
الصلاحيات المطلقه وليس في كل ما احتجنا
اليه من امر بقى ينتظر لاسابيع متى ياتي
ردكم من صعدا الضمانه الحقيقيه هي متى
سيسلم هذه الجماعه السلاحي للدوله متى
الدوله تتعامل بجديه ومسؤوليه الان رئيس
الجمهوريه استشعر مسؤوليته التاريخيه امام
هذا الوضع وشكل لجنه وكلف الحكومه بتطبيع
الاوضاع والزم وطالب الحوثيين بلهجه قويه
ان يتم تسليم جميع الاسلحه التي بايديهم
الى الدوله وان ينخرطوا في تشكيل الحزب في
في العمل السياسي المدني وفي صياغه مستقبل
الدوله الاتحاديه القادمه خاصه وهم كانوا
جزء مكون الحوار الوطني الشامل الذي انتهى
في مارس الماضي ليس امم الحوثيين الا ان
يكون حزب مدني او ان تظل حركه ديناميت
وظيفتها القاتل وتفجير جماجم الناس حتى او
هنا نقطه مهمه اريد التنبيه ال نقطتين
الاولى ان لم تسقط عمران بقدر ما سقطت
احزاب اللقاء مشترك الاشتراكي الحزب
التاريخي العريق لا ادري اين ذهب الناصر
اصدر بيان
منت حتى نعود لتفاصيل فق حتى لا نعود الى
تفاصيل ماجر يعني بعد اذنك يعني حتى نحترم
منهج الحلقه على الاقل ونفهم نحن الان
نتحدث عن الضمانات المطلوبه لتكرار لعدم
تكرار ما
جرى يعني بعد اذنك بعد
اذنك هناك تحذير من مجلس الامن لكل
الاطراف التي يمكن ان تعرقل مسار المصالحه
الوطنيه ايه
والبعض يعتبر بان هذا ربما الذي شجع
الحوثيين على التعاطي بشكل افضل في في
عمران تحذير مجلس الامن ما الذي يمكن ان
يرافقه
كضمانات حتى اقليميه لانه يقال دائما ان
الحوثيين مدعومين من ايران وهم ينكرون ذلك
طبعا كيف يمكن لنا ان نحصل على ضمانات
اقليميه وحتى دوليه لجعل مسار المصالحه في
اليمن والتقدم افضل مما هو الان وهو متعثر
اعتقد ان الضامن الرئيسي هو دور انا يعني
ربما اختلف مع الاخ عارف انه الرئاسه
والحكومه لم تقم بواجبها تجاه ما حدث
الضامن الرئيسي هو ان يستثمر عبد الربو
منصور ما حصل وان يعني يقوم باجراءات
عمليه وعلى ارض الواقع بنزع السلاح من كل
المليشيات المسلحه وزاره الدفاع تلمح
باكثر من مره ان هناك الذي يواجه
الحوثييون هناك مليشيات اخرى الاصل ان يتم
نزع السلاح وان تتم وان تكون الدوله هي
المالك الرئيسي للسلاح ما حدث في عمران
وقرار مجلس الامن يمكن ان تستثمر الحكومه
اليمنيه يمكن ان تستثمر الرس في اليمن
يمكن ان تستثمر وزاره الدفاع بان اولا يتم
عمل اجراءات على ارض الواقع في نزع السلاح
من كل القوى منن كل المليشيات ايا تنتمي
لاي مكون كان الشياء الثاني هو ان تقوم
بعمل تحقيق ومكاشفة
لظه التي يتم هناك تشكيل لجنه لبناء
الدستور يختلق هذا الصراع ويتم هذا التوسع
المسلح لاعا الدوله المدنيه الذي التي يرى
هذه المكونات المتصارعه وعلى راسها الحوثي
ترى انه ليس من مصلحتها ان تكون هناك دوله
لان بوجود الدوله لن يكون لها وجود حقيقي
على الارض ننوه مره اخرى بان لحد الان
للاسف الاتصال متعذر بالسيد محمد العماد
الخبير في شؤون الحوثيين الذي كان بامكانه
ان يعطينا على الاقل فكره عما يفكر فيه
هؤلاء في هذه القضايا التي اثرنا منذ
البدايه نسال سيد عارف ابو حاتم في ظل
زياره الرئيس عبد الربو منصور هذه الاخيره
الى السعوديه وال الدور الذي يمكن ان
تلعبه دول الجوار في ترتيب اوضاع افضل من
الحاليه الان في اليمن هل يمكن التعويل
على هذا
الجانب دول الجوار مطالبه اولا ان تواجه
نفسها بالسؤال الجوهري والهام وهو
كم مره حدث خلال السبعين السنه الماضيه ان
حركه الاخوان المسلمين وقفت ضدهم او تامرت
معهم ان حتى في علم السياسه ان الانقلابات
والشغب والاحتجاجات تحدث في الدول الاقل
في خدمات المعيشه الدول تعاني من شظف
العيش اما في دول تعا يوجد فيها رفاهيه
الصحه والتعليم والمعيشه والسكن لا يفكروا
بالانقلابات لا يمكن للاخوان المسلمين ان
يقنع الشارع الخليجي بالانقلاب على حكومته
بالتالي يجب على دول الخليج الا تفكر
بتنميه العضله الحوثيه في مواجهه الاخوان
المسلمين خاصه وان اخوان اليمن كانوا طوال
السنوات الماضيه لا يرون في السعوديه حتى
هذه اللحظه لا يرون فيها الا خيرا خالصا
حتى الجمعه الماضيه كانوا يصلون ويرفعون
صوار الملك عبد الله والعلم السعودي في
ساحه في ساحه الثوره الشارع 60 على دول
الجوار ان تستشعر الخطر من هذا المد
القادم الان الحوثي بيده ترسانه عسكريه
بامكانها ان تلتف شمالا وتقتحم الحدود
السعوديه وان تدخل في مواجهات مع الحكومه
السعوديه نعم يعني بعد اذنك يعني بعد اذنك
الان التحق بنا اخيرا اخيرا محمد العماد
الخبير في الشؤون شؤون الحوثيين اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد
عماد حتى نتلافى على الاقل ما سبق من من
نقاط بشكل سريع في صيغه اسئله سريعه
واجابات سريعه هل تعتقد سيد العماد بان
الترتيبات او التفاهمات الجاريه الان في
عمران مؤشر على علاقه افضل ربما في
المستقبل بين الحوثيين
والحكومه
اكيد ما قام ما قام به من مبادرات انصار
الله الاكثر من مره ورسائل
الرئيس لجميع الاطراف في تهدئه الوضع فهي
هي رسائل ستكون ايجابيه وستحقق في الايام
القريبه جدا جدا وسيعلم اليمنيين بان هناك
مفاجاه ستحصل على مستوى الوجود الحكومي في
الايام القريبه وتمثيل والتمثيل الكامل
للدوله هناك والذي حصل وال واعتقد ان كان
وفد من من قناه الجزيره امس تم تغطيه ما
يحدث في عمران وتسليم بعض المقرات هناك
وهم موجودين على الساحه اخي ولكن الحكومه
تتهم هؤلاء بال بالمماطلة
للنزول الحكومه هي طرف لان الحكومه تم
تاسيسها من طرفي هم طرفي طرفي الصراع
السابق الصراع السابق والحلفاء وحلفاء 90
بمعنى الحكومه الحكومه معروفه والمهيمن
عليها
هو باكثر من النصف وان كانت بعض الصور
مطروحه امام مكونات اخرى ولكن الحكومه
معروفه بان هي تتبع جناح الاصلاح ولهذا
يجب ان يكون موقفها معادي لان ما يحدث في
في الساحه على ما طرح البيان الاتحاد
الاتحاد الاوروبي بان هناك راع بين
الاصلاح وتنظيم انصار الله هناك تحذير كان
من مجلس الامن الدولي لمعاقبه من يعرقل
وكانت هناك اشاره فهم منها بان الحوثيين
معنيين بذلك هل تعتقد بان هذا التحذير
الدولي ان فهم كذلك قادر على ان يؤثر بشكل
جيد في مسار
الاحداث
ان شاء الله يكون التحذير الدولي اولا لم
يطرح اسم انصار الله فقط التحذير الدولي
طرح اسم المنظمات بشكل عام اما
بشكل ان نطرح بانه التحذير كان لانصار
الله فهذا شيء مجحف الشيء الاخر على ما
اعتقد عندما يتم تحذير طرف معين استغرب
فيما سوف يمسك عليها المجتمع الدولي هل
انصار الله لديهم تشكيله وسط الحكومه هل
انصار الله لديهم ارصده في الخارج هل
انصار الله لديهم شركات وسط العاصمه انصار
الله هم حركه جديده ولهذا لا ينفع ان ان
نستدعي الخارج لحل المشاكل وسط الساحه
اليمنيه يجب ان ان ان نبادر الجميع الى ما
طرحه
ئ هذه الحركه هل هي مستعده نعم هذه الحركه
كسؤال اخير هذه الحركه هل هي مستعده
لالقاء السلاح والمشاركه في دوله مدنيه لا
تكون فيها هناك عباره عن ميليشيات هنا
وهناك سواء الاصلاح او غير الاصلاح او
الحوثيين او غيرهم
اخي العزيز بكلمتين اذا كانت هذه الحركه
ليست مستعده فلماذا قائد جماعه انصار الله
يلح دائما في خطابه في يجب ان نطبق مخرجات
الحوار للاسف الان يمسكون البعض البعض
يريد ان يطبق في مخرجات الحوار بعض النقط
لا مخرجات الحوار هي مجموعه متكامله حزمه
متكامله يجب تنفيذها على مستوى الساحه
اليمنيه والا نجز نقطه فقط شكرا لك سييد
محمد العماد الخبير في شؤون الحوثيين
والذي التحق بنا متاخرا للاسف فبالتالي لم
يشارك معنا في كل النقاط التي اثرنا شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا عارف ابو حاتم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من صنعاء وهنا في الاستديو الكاتب
والباحث اليمني جمال المليكي في امان
الله
ه